qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
dans ce 1 nu
ne soyez pas agressif j'y suis pas
agressive je précise
[Musique]
Pigalle 22h la nuit s'ouvre claire
Isabelle Natty elles sont 40 qui de
boite en boîte de quart d'heure en quart
d'heure mène la ronde des strip-tease à
15 francs
à Pigalle Luan Pigalle claire Isabelle
Natti
[Musique]
j'ai appris qu'on cherchait les
danseuses à Tabarin je me suis présentée
[Musique]
et puis j'étais engagé
alors le jour j'allais en classe le soir
j'allais danser ma mère venue me
chercher
[Musique]
et puis un jour je me suis retrouvée nue
sur la scène du Mayol
j'ai jamais été
[Musique]
aussi misérable dans ma vie que ce
jour-là
[Musique]
il y a combien de temps
et puis
le sport j'avais décidé quatre ans je
m'arrêterai je ne savais pas que c'était
30 ans de métier je crois que c'était 30
ans d'âge maintenant ça va bien faire
trois temps de métier que je fais ça
j'ai commencé comme danseuse
et puis
un peu moins de danse
[Musique]
la première fois de cette terre elles
ont disparu
[Musique]
parce que généralement quand on va dans
une nouvelle boîte c'est toujours
une nouvelle découverte c'est c'est
idiot à dire parce que c'est vraiment
mineur le strip-te
[Musique]
il vous arrive de faire votre numéro
pour une personne souvent bien bien
souvent
[Musique]
quand je vois une lueur de sympathie je
m'y accroche comme un bruit de sauvetage
parce que vraiment il y a des fois
la nuit va être dur et l'argent est cher
cette année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
chose délicate je vais mettre les faux
cils
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avouez dans dans la vie
votre métier vous dites je suis
stripteaseuse
parce que je sais pas mentir je sais pas
improviser je sais pas mentir alors
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
[Musique]
ne soyez pas agressif j'y suis pas
agressive je précise
un définitif je crois que
on croit que je suis agressive je suis
pas tellement pas enfin normalement quoi
normalement névrosé et quelle est la
réaction des gens
à ces mots de danseuse
[Musique]
ça dépend le rééducation
il a beaucoup qui sont tout simplement
polie
mais maintenant ça va mieux quand même
avec l'âge il se demande comment
j'arrive
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez des regrets par
rapport à quelque chose que vous auriez
souhaité justement petite fille je
regrets oui certainement j'aurais
aimé avoir du talent avoir le courage de
travailler
et de faire une carrière artistique
plutôt qu'une carrière de string enfin
une carrière oui ça m'a fait vivre
jusqu'à présent ça va encore me faire
vivre pendant quelques jours quelques
quelques mois quelques années quelques
semaines peut-être demain on sait pas
peut-être tous aller au charbon ailleurs
mais
[Musique]
ça m'a permis de gagner honnêtement ma
vie honnêtement pour moi
je n'ai jamais tué j'ai jamais volé j'ai
jamais fait quelque chose de vraiment
moche à qui que ce soit je pense que
j'ai mené ma vie
tranquille j'ai pas fait un bien immense
mais j'ai pas fait de mal c'est déjà une
bonne chose alors dans ce
contexte
je n'ai pas honte parce que ça vous
permet de gagner votre vie est-ce que
vous y trouver un plaisir de faire ces
numéros chaque soir
je le fais le mieux que je peux
comme je fais le mieux que je peux
ça va c'est
pas que
ses pieds mais en face c'est parfois ça
arrive parfois c'est
j'arrive à croire que je suis pas dénuée
d'intérêt sur une scène
[Musique]
et pour débuter cette merveilleuse
seconde partie une sœur à moi absolument
à un comparable et les jeunes et les
jolies et les riches et
ici dans les conditions pareilles
d'ailleurs elles appellent claire Nevers
pourquoi vert et bien parce que le vert
est tout simplement la couleur de
l'espérance mais oui madame voici donc
pour vous ce soir claire Nevers la plus
émouvante la plus charmante la plus
typique des gigantesques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a combien de temps il s'appelle que
vous faites ce métier 3 mois
[Musique]
de février
et comment vous avez commencé comme ça
il fallait que je gagne un peu d'argent
au début alors
faut que je fasse quelque chose
[Musique]
avant vous alliez
à l'école
à 15 ans à peu près
et là il a fallu que vous gagnez votre
vie et vous avez décidé de d'aller faire
du strip-tease non
j'ai fait un peu j'ai fait un peu de
gala comme ça
puis après j'ai fait la régie et puis
comme la boîte où j'ai travaillé ça fait
un mais je devienne obligé de gagner ma
vie alors j'ai fait ça
[Musique]
et vos parents que ce qui comment ils
ont réagi une fois confiance
[Musique]
alors la première fois que vous êtes
passé comment
quand même de passer sur cinq comme ça
tout le monde vous regarde
vous pensiez quoi vous pensez quoi des
gens qui étaient devant vous
[Musique]
moi personnellement je pensais que
j'étais un peu ridicule tout ça alors
[Musique]
moi je pensais pas pour les autres je
pensais plutôt pour moi
un peu peur c'est impressionnant
et maintenant aujourd'hui
ça va c'est la routine
[Musique]
30 km de Paris à peu près
alors vous partez une heure avant de
chez vous
[Musique]
de trajet et le temps que je me
réchauffe un peu dans la loge et puis je
me maquille
[Musique]
il faut quand même 5 minutes pour me
maquiller préparer mes affaires tout
et ensuite de boîte en bois vous allez
comment vous faites tous les trajets
mais à l'extérieur c'est un moi je
prends chez ma mobylette
[Musique]
et à 3h vous reprenez votre mot de lait
voilà et puis je m'en vais
[Musique]
vous voyez parfois des anciennes amis
des amis d'école
non je
non pas du tout
[Musique]
les amis vous avez maintenant ça savent
toutes que vous faites ce que vous bah
je le vois plus alors donc le savent pas
je dirais pas impossible
[Musique]
si je dis que je suis triste et ils vont
dire c'est une fille facile et tout ça
non je préfère pas je préfère dire
carrément je suis une danseuse et puis
c'est tout
[Musique]
dans la tête des gens l'image du
strip-tease
[Musique]
finalement
est-ce que vous quand vous regardez
comme ça vous faites depuis 3 mois ce
métier est-ce que vous aurez envie de
faire autre chose oui j'aurais
possibilité de faire autre chose je le
ferai oui
[Musique]
disons que
je ferai toujours danseuse mais pas dans
pas dans le Strip
je pouvais me situer dans un truc
pas faire danseuse dans une revue ou un
truc comme ça je le ferai
c'est le fait de vous mettre nu toute
seule comme ça
[Musique]
et quand vous étiez beaucoup plus jeune
quand vous étiez petite fille vous aviez
envie de faire croire j'ai toujours fait
de la danse
je voulais vraiment
rentrer dans une revue je voyais ça
rendez vous et puis en fin de compte
je fais comme tout le monde j'ai fait le
Strip de tout
c'est pas facile de trouver du travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous présenter maintenant une
sœur à moi absolument adorable et les
jeunes et les blondes elle est très
jolie elle se déshabille avec une grâce
infinie elle a des plus charmants non
qui soit elle s'appelle Isabelle
assoupi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui native
ou conditions de travail
très mauvaise parce que
d'abord du fait qu'on est très très peu
payé alors beaucoup pour en faire
beaucoup faut faire des petits numéros
qui dure 4 minutes
alors voilà vous êtes payé combien
écoutez il y a des il y a toutes sortes
de prix vous avez le stripad 10 francs
et puis le Strip A40 alors ça dépend ça
dépend des boîtes ça dépend des filles
ça dépend de beaucoup de choses ça
dépend aussi de l'intelligence du patron
parce que en fait c'est une fille fait
inscrit pas dit francs est évident
qu'elle fera elle en fera pour 10 francs
c'est déjà trop
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
parce que dans la vie aussi vous êtes
strip-teaseuse je vous dirai ce que vous
avez honte parfois de votre métier bon à
la main je vais vous dire
je finis
[Musique]
ça c'est un problème parce
que vous dites à quelqu'un vous faites
du strip-tease on va vous regarder notre
salaire vous comprenez je sais pas
pourquoi parce que vous savez une
stripteaseuse est aussi honnête qu'une
femme de ménage d'abord
elle est aussi une autre qu'une femme de
ménage et aucune bureaucrade qu'une
secrétaire clé de banque que n'importe
mais les gens vous allez dire à
quelqu'un tiens moi je suis Madame
Claude vous êtes chez Madame Claude
du respect pour vous
[Musique]
d'argent que les filles qui sont chez
Madame Claude je sais pas il y a un
problème là mais il y a une espèce de de
barrière des gens on dit strip-teaseuses
d'abord en fait on le dit pas on dit on
est danseuse
moi je dirais rarement que je suis
strip-teaseuse si on me dit en fait du
nu aussi ah oui je dis oui alors là je
me mets à l'aise mais sinon je n'ose pas
affronter les gens dire oui je suis
strip-teaseuse dans la vie dans la rue
la sécurité sociale ou à la banque
j'oserai jamais dire je suis
stripteaseuse c'est ridicule parce que
c'est je fais rien de mal hein
[Musique]
pas du tout non parce que les gens ne
comprennent mes parents c'est les gens
ils comprennent pas
[Musique]
dans ma vie et le peu que j'ai eu ils
ont accepté
[Musique]
mais avant c'est marrant ça que je n'ai
pas du tout
voilà
[Musique]
vous êtes seul ça vous pose pas de grave
problème pas du tout ça m'imposerait si
j'étais avec quelqu'un
parce que
ça me pose pas de problème parce que je
j'essaie je vais essayer maintenant de
m'organiser pour l'avenir vous comprenez
pour quand je ne pourrai plus faire du
strip-tease si je n'aime bon bah quand
je pourrais plus faire de strip-tease
j'aimerais bien avoir acheté des petits
appartements comme ça que je mourrai et
j'aurais un petit revenu vous comprenez
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je fais
je suis défigurée ou il manque une jambe
qu'est-ce que je vais devenir alors je
suis obligée de faire attention
parce que j'ai pas j'ai jamais fait
attention jusqu'à présent alors
maintenant je suis obligée
et c'est pour ça qu'il vaut mieux être
seul en fait voyez parce que on fait
vraiment ce qu'on veut de son argent on
dépense mon dépense pas moi je suis très
heureuse comme ça
[Musique]
partout partout partout
c'est pas non plus extraordinaire
seulement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'elle était espagnole or en
principe les Espagnols sont brunes très
rares les Espagnols blondes et bien
voici la plus blonde de nos espagnols
voici Nadine viens ma chérie viens viens
vite ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]